true story there was a former under
Secretary of Defense who was invited to
speak at a large conference like a
thousand people and in the middle of his
remarks he was holding a cup of coffee
in a styrofoam cup and he and he looks
down and he smiles and he interrupts
himself and he says you
know last year I I was still the under
secretary and I spoke at this exact same
cover and last year they flew me here
business class there was someone waiting
for me at the airport to drive me to the
hotel someone had already checked me
into the hotel and I just went back you
know they took me up to my room I came
down in the morning there was somebody
waiting for me in the lobby and they
brought me to the same venue they took
me through to the back entrance and they
took me into a green room and they
handed me a cup of coffee in a beautiful
ceramic cup he says I'm no longer the
under secretary I flew here coach I took
a taxi from the hotel to the from the
airport to the hotel I took another taxi
this morning to the venue I came in the
front door found my way back backstage
and I when I asked somebody do you have
any coffee they pointed to the coffee
machine in the corner and I poured
myself a cup of coffee into this here
Styrofoam cup was never meant for me it
was meant for the position I held I
deserve a styrofoam cup and the great
leaders all recognize that you can enjoy
the ceramic cup you can enjoy the first
class you can enjoy the nicer office
absolutely enjoy it but they're not
giving it to you they're giving to the
position you hold either in the company
or in the social hierarchy we all
deserve a styrofoam cup and for the
leaders that REM are remember that
you'll do just fine